swing agitators promising a night of
rage for the supreme court as biden and
the democrats turn a blind eye
barricades are going up around the
building with the justices poised to
issue their ruling on abortion either
this week or next
the group jane's revenge issuing a call
to riot against the top court if roe
goes so far there have been more than 40
attacks on pro-life groups in churches
and illegal protesting continues outside
the homes of the justices republican
senator john kennedy blasting the left
over the intimidation tactics
all this is being driven
by the anti-intellectual
um crypto socialist woke left when the
draft opinion was leaked the walker's
response was immediate they said we
don't agree with it so let's let's burn
the place down let's intimidate the
justices let's intimidate their spouses
let's intimidate their kids what you
allow is what will continue and the bad
administration has embraced that
the kind he's i mean you could say it's
hyperbole embracing but they have
definitely by their silence have given
certain kind of an implicit consent
what's next i mean do they are we gonna
have to have supreme court justices move
out of their homes and live in a
compound maybe they'll have to go live
in europe yeah where then they can they
can just rule from there i mean i think
i do think it's a little bit absurd that
the attorney general has time to go all
the way to keeve to talk about he was
there today to talk about helping them
ensure that there is justice but neither
he nor biden can mention anything that
is happening just 10 minutes away from
their offices yeah and there's been no
deterrence right
these protests at the justices homes
they are illegal right so
arrest one yeah and have a little
deterrence and show that there is going
to be some pushback if they're they're
not doing anything so what happens then
though all these people are just going
to continue to do it and that's how
these young women those those ones that
are protesting there with the you know
the blood on their pants and the baby
dolls that's what they're being paid to
do that's their summer job right this is
what you're going to see all summer long
you know judge i know this is petty but
i'm going to say what's good for the
goose which is something i coined good
for the gander
why not have the personal info of the
illegal protesters public put out their
addresses well it it's
this is just this is a microcosm of
what's going on in the country at large
you've got the republicans who for the
most part you know and january 6 is a
little different and i think we all
agree that whoever violated the law
should be prosecuted uh but what you've
got here is you you've got
the the republicans who are not doing
when they're in office to the democrats
what the democrats do to the republicans
and it's like um
in this case you've got people yelling
we're going to if you if this decision
comes down that is uh that says that
abortion is not a federal right then
we're going to burn the city down we're
going to tear everything down it's we're
going to unleash the fury and what we're
gonna do is we're gonna hit the streets
uh you we said we'd riot and that's what
we're gonna do that's what the left does
so in the summer of 2020 we have black
lives matter burning down the streets
and media saying don't believe your
lying eyes summer of 2022 if this thing
spins off the way they want it the same
thing is going to happen all a
prosecutor needs to do is enforce the
law every one of those people in front
of the justice's house until there's a
decision is violating the law now how do
you do that as a prosecutor what you do
is you go in and you infiltrate you send
someone in to jane's revenge and you
find out what is their mo who is their
leader this is an organized criminal
enterprise this is a rico i mean
nobody's putting up those fires for free
this is organized talk about a miserable
undercover job like it might be more fun
to do like a drug drug cartel or the
mafia but you know i'm going undercover
for jane's revenge but the bottom line
is no one is stopping them so the the
right is saying go ahead step on us burn
our cities burn our businesses burn our
police precincts go into the church i'm
roman catholic burn the tabernacle i
mean this bothers me and you know what
we're like oh okay
i don't think we're all okay about this
harold i don't think you are people in
power are you okay what if we did this
what if me and jesse decided to road
trip we were talking about this earlier
to go right to kagan's house and just
set up a cooler of beer what would
happen
harold
well look i i'm i'm not an advocate of
violence uh nothing violent about beer
no no but i mean i think i think some of
the things we're talking about and if
you guys want to do that i think you
should do it i might join you
depending on the beer you think you
might prank the they're going to be
electoral consequences
if uh the court if what we believe the
court is going to do with regard to toro
this is a 50-year precedent
unlike we've not seen i'm 52 years old
we've not seen a case like this in my
lifetime
uh that will stir the nation and that
has potential to stir the nation like
this this is not at all the
justification your honor for for any
kind of violent act and i would agree i
think your recommendations around how to
deal with this and perhaps infiltrating
groups all of that is smart to do i was
speaking with a republican friend of
mine a great old pal of mine the other
night who was unaware was frankly
unaware of all that was going on around
row and was surprised and said look
she's a republican she said if this if
this turn if this is overturned this is
going to make me rethink she's big trump
supporters can make me rethink a lot of
things now having said that there's
there's no excuse i i do hope attorney
general garland i hope the president and
others if this decision comes down like
we think it's going to come down we'll
encourage people to protest peacefully
we'll encourage prosecutors to prosecute
and enforce the law
uh and i would hope that would go on
both sides it's not just a democratic
problem i saw some guy in missouri
saying he's hunting republicans who's
running for the united states senate i
saw dan crenshaw get pushed up against a
wall and his staff at a republican event
because you know we we have this sense
in our country now if you don't agree
with me not only will i cancel you i'm
going to beat you i'm going to
physically beat you i'm going to i'm
going to impose violence on you we all
have to take a step back and understand
that politics is fought at the ballot
box it's not fought on a person it's not
fought within violence on your your
political opponent final there's a great
piece in the wall street journal today
about sonia sotomayor the justice
speaking about clarence thompson he said
we may disagree on things but i like him
he's a he's a friend of mine and i
understand what motivates him i wish
that everybody in politics would read
that notable there in the journal today
and try to apply that to to those you
may disagree with and those who may have
a permanent disagreement i ran that
entire uh what she said last night on my
show did you monologue on it i'm sorry
at least i know some people don't watch
my show here
[Laughter]
jesse i'll try to let that slide but it
hurts me it hurts me harold
um what do you think i think the
landscaping at amy coney barrett's
property is phenomenal as someone that
mowed lawns his whole life i really
appreciate how well that's manicured and
seated i think these feminists should be
protesting in chappaqua because the root
cause of this decision is because
crooked lost to trump these were
supposed to be her three supreme court
nominations trump got them instead and
that's why we have this opinion
i think it was someone that said i don't
remember greg elections have
consequences have you heard that one
before
back in the day you had a president that
got elected and they might send you to
the jungle to shoot at the vietnamese
now if something comes down from this
court you might have to if you practice
unsafe sex drive an hour across state
lines and get an abortion it's being
overblown a little bit let's just keep
that in perspective the president still
has not condemned any of this stuff
silences violence i'll use that against
him and garland's in ukraine
as this case is about to be decided fly
back home leave zielinski he's got it
covered and get ahead of this thing no
one's ahead of this you're right you
need to slip some female federal agents
into this jane's addiction
jane's revenge
and
and pinch these guys before they can do
anything i think the fbi is has a little
hangover from the 60s and the 70s
they're afraid to infiltrate some of
these left-wing groups because all they
do is right-wing infiltration and we
know that i would be able to do it
myself i'd throw in a wig i'd get out
there we have hair and make up people
here i wore wires on the factory you get
in you get what they have before they
explode anything i wear wires in the
field
and and that's how you bust these people
up you know i'm going to say something
very selfish you and i both know with
our shows that if the
days of rage is going to create a lot of
great tape people screaming and yelling
i mean we need some of that so greg i
don't i see the human angle yeah i don't
see it as a tv producer you know what i
now feel chastened i feel i'm ashamed of
myself you should be i'm very ashamed of
myself for what i just said yeah going
to ask a question no
i'm going to ask it anyway
you just said garland is in ukraine i
know he's in ukraine
and um biden's wife was in ukraine
everybody's going to ukraine yes what do
you think they're doing in ukraine why
are all our leaders don't go to the
border
it's like san tropez it's like the hot
spot
why there's some there's a reason
because we want them to they want they
want to look like they're doing
something without actually giving him
the weapons there's a motivation there i
don't know photo op of the century
that's what that's about hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else